Hello again, this is Dr. Cudders in section 20 of stop fighting cancer. This you know may be the most important section of all
Is in this section I lay out ten steps with that you should follow with every cancer
Patient and this really is a section that you can take to your doctor and say are we dealing with this?
Well, maybe you shouldn't take to your oncologist because they're not dealing with it
Take to your natural medicine doctor
If not read through these you should try to be accomplishing each one of these different steps, and it's not a step one step two
per se as shown in the diagram that you see here
It is really a puzzle that you want to put together in each one of these these
10 pieces of puzzle that you want to place together
You want to be accomplishing them. That's partly why I love my medicine
Mushroom, it's not just mushrooms in there
It's some other things that we accomplished about seven or eight of these puzzle pieces just with that mix alone
Don't be at all. I am not a nutrition pusher
So even though I got a zillion nutritional things that are really good for cancer patients in this book of course
It comes to me. We test them out and they're on and I have some cancer patients on one thing
So it is I'd rather take a minimalistic approach because
Too much of a good thing is a bad thing and anything that you absorb that your body can't use right now
Your liver has to detoxify
So you're better off with a minimalistic approach and really doing this through diet more than anything
But put these puzzle pieces together look at all 10 of them take some time to go over them bring them to your functional doctor
If you have one and try to get some help make sure you use good products if you're going to use them
If he has a way or she has a way of tests you order them make sure you do that
So they're not you have to follow each one of these steps, but you but you do want to at least address these steps
So I hope that you do all right
I hope this is a blessing to you and I will see you in the last section